but speaking of fedor if we take you out
of the picture
who are the greatest mixed martial arts
fighters of all time uh i
i feel you out of the picture
as a cop out to some degree i feel like
we need a little bit more time
you know so to to to see how how this
unfolds
because you got to compare a lot of
things and i uh
did i did i think i'm like i did an
interview
i don't know about centuries but that
would help if we can keep accurate
records and not allow
uh too much uh bias to fall into too
much profit
right yeah but um i made
an argument uh i was in a i get a
it was a interview with an mma outlet of
some sort and i can't recall who it was
but oh it was argument about will the
winner of
cain velasquez versus stephen yochik be
the greatest mma heavyweight of all time
and i said
[ __ ] no way oh no it's cormier
and miocic that's what it was i said
absolutely not
not even close and i said these guys
need a bit more time to see
how things go and also how things go for
some of their opponents and like
there's more factors than just this one
fight it really is and i go
and when you want to weigh these people
even if let's say we'll bring aleister
or uh yeah aleister overeem into the end
of the equation
okay you judge him on what you know now
what he's done for you lately okay right
which is a very myopic way of doing it
what has he done over his career k1
champion
uh he was a champion in um
uh dream um he strike force
blah blah blah his overall record the
entirety of all
the different opponents he's fought and
i just sit back and go
okay he's not the ufc champ but
his accolades his merits
in some ways actually stand up
higher than cormiers and miocic
is so what about the moments do you give
much value to the special
moments like the highest heights you
rise to not in terms of records
or the strikes landed but just creating
a magical moment
in in a in in a fight it doesn't have to
be even a championship fight
but just you know conor mcgregor is an
example of somebody who creates a
narrative who gets a story he creates a
drama
and a special magic happens even if it's
like not
myth is greater than reality and that is
always the case but
do you and so i understand that so very
much and it takes
an [ __ ] like me to to poo poo on your
myth
yeah they at least get you at the end of
the day you're not going to abandon your
myth
but um perhaps temper it with
the facts and logic but uh so you're not
a fan of myth
no i'm an absolute massive fan of myth
but you prefer facts and logic it's like
when i i know i mean
i like saying facts and logic because
people i also
i am not a materialist in that sense i
don't think that materialism can solve
for everything it's not enough it's not
it's not robust enough
i'm sorry if facts and logic and or uh
reason
as the enlightenment scholars all
thought including marx
was enough for people then
we would never we wouldn't have any
religions yeah we wouldn't have
there would be no we wouldn't have
narratives and myths and all this kind
of stuff
it would not it just i'm sorry there is
no there's nothing
about history that supports the idea
that
rationality will over will overcome all
there's something about
ben shapiro's facts don't care about
your feelings that feels to be mis
fields be missing something fundamental
about human nature it's not
clear to me exactly what is missing to
give ol
oh oh oh oh oh ben uh a fair
shake and uh you know i don't know ben
shapiro
i don't really listen to ben shapiro not
against ben shapiro
um i don't i'm not here to say anything
particularly bad about him
um although i will say at one time tom
arnold was
seemingly trying to pick an actual fight
with ben shapiro
in the ring or somewhere yeah and i just
and i actually responded like art and i
tried to get him to clarify say hey
are you saying that you want to fight
ben shapiro that you're looking to
actually because i was waiting for him
to say something and then i'd be like
okay
well it's one thing to want to get into
a fight with someone it's another thing
to go pick on
a little tiny you know guy like ben
who's much smaller than you and doesn't
train or whatever but you know if it's
not me i can find
someone your size and you can go fight
him you know don't be a
basically don't be a bully piece of [ __ ]
yeah you know
which by the way tom arnold you are a
mental [ __ ] you are never going to be
able to
compete even with ben shapiro in an
argument on any level
about anything oh intellectual argument
yeah an intellectual argument you could
scr
maybe you can scream louder than him but
whatever
but nevertheless in the discussion of
greatness in fighting i think you you
need to
all right numbers you need those numbers
the numbers and there's the magic
there is some context also in that where
did aleister overeem fight
oh we found pride where you could soccer
kick people and stomp their heads and
this and that and so the the
the the game environment is actually
different too
so more uncertainty there's more
characters and pride there's more
go back a little further and go like
what about the guys used to like
dan severn fought bare knuckle head
butts the whole nine
beat death seven right i did beat dan
severan that was that was killing an
idol
so to speak although i didn't really
kill him because i still love him
you know he's still an eye i mean he's
still responsible for inspiration
along this whole pathway you know it's
it's meeting meeting your god and then
putting a knife in it i guess they can't
uh
realizing they're human and then
bringing them down to your level
exactly but also there's a there's a
huge misconception there and that is
that i could bring maybe i could bring
dan severan down to my level
but i couldn't bring his mustache down
to my level oh it is it is of mythic
proportions
and uh greater than yours your facial
hair is greater than yours my facial
hair is
is is is creating its own legacy but it
is not dan severn
mustache level or no don fry mustache so
don fry mustache dance ever mustache
you know now you have like shia versus
sunni like
do you think there will be uh karl marx
uh like painting of josh barnett one day
with the beard and is that is that
basically i hope so i'll
i will actually comb my hair unlike marx
but uh
um chaos is uh has a charm to it
it does it does i mean uh we all thought
doc brown in back to the future was
was quite charming so uh you have to
throw that into the calculation where
they fought
yes this is the and the rules that they
fought under you know some guy like
eager of
changing won a 32-man tournament or
something like that i go okay
uh stephen and daniel cormier are
awesome and they may they will they will
for sure
be uh revered as
when they're as for their careers one
hundred percent
can you say that they're particularly
even better
overall than eager of changing maybe one
of them could have beat them maybe maybe
one of them wouldn't have
you know maybe maybe here would have
[ __ ] got him with the knuckles
right away well maybe if they fought him
in pride they wouldn't have won maybe if
they fought him
bare knuckle they wouldn't won i don't
know and there's something about the cat
like do you put
who is gracie in the top 10 you know
there's something about uh top ten of
all time
in terms of competitors
is capable um i don't know i'd have to
think about that maybe not
but i tracy as like pyramid level
like wow dude what a what an amazing man
oh yeah he's so important
absolutely incredibly important but
there's something about
stepping into uh like fighting another
human being
under all the uncertainty that the early
ufc's had i mean you don't know
yup what is going to happen and couple
that
with not much money all of it
yes so that the purity of it too there's
something about money
i mean that i guess [ __ ] for that yes
world but
that ruins the purity of the violence
yeah people
given the opportunity for
yeah yeah well the bigger things get the
more i love the fact that that
fighting has opened up to such a degree
that the
career business side of it because i i
absolutely distinctly separate the two
the business side of it has
opened up to give me far more
possibilities opened way more doors for
me than i ever intended it to
uh whereas the
athlete side of things has if anything
just gotten substantially worse
i would say and uh some of this can be
some of this is due to all the
the nature of all games will be learned
will be gamed uh without even
the rules being broken and once that's
figured out you need to make an
adjustment
no adjustments have been made so the
game just
appears to be the same game over and
over and over and over and over again
on espn plus um whatever on whatever on
whatever
it doesn't really matter which night you
watch it's the same game
constantly and that's not because the
the the athletes are worse or better
it's because
they have had that game structure long
enough that they figured out
what do you do to be to be the most
successful at it what is the highest
percentage way of approaching it
essentially even if you're not thinking
of percentages
you